covid patients are pouring into Chinese
hospitals while funeral homes are packed
full
the consequences of Beijing abruptly
ending its covet zero policy China has
suddenly loosened up its restrictions
left and right and that's just provided
an extraordinary opportunity for this
virus to just like a volcano explode
that volcano could unleash new variants
that will eventually land in other
countries suddenly one place become the
week's link of the whole world ready for
something as of next week the United
States will require negative kova tests
for passengers from China as young as
two years old and regardless of their
nationality or whether they're fully
vaccinated cases are surging in a
country with little immunity and
relatively low vaccination rates
the U.S now joins a growing list of
countries Japan India Taiwan and Italy
are all bringing in similar rules
for now the Canadian government has no
plans on doing the same Canada took an
evidence-based approach when it came to
health protocols at the border obviously
this is a situation that we're
monitoring very very closely but there
are questions about how effective
airport testing really is travel
restrictions at the start of the
pandemic were not able to keep new
variants out
the Chinese foreign Ministry says
countries should take what it calls a
science-based Approach at the moment
there is no obvious indication there are
any new variants emerging from China but
the problem we have is we have so little
data from China that we really don't
know what's going on and was so little
known there are fears this will be the
worst outbreak since the start of the
pandemic
teriya isri Global News
Ottawa